let's bring in chief washington
correspondent major garrett major good
morning to you
so the democrats did what is regarded as
a pretty good job in reminding people of
the emotion and the power
and how scary that day was january 6 but
they still need 11 more votes to move
into their column if they want to get to
a conviction
how are they going to go about doing
that well they're going to say that what
happened on january 6th was not an
isolated incident that it was the
culmination of a campaign that sought to
undermine the constitution
undermine support in our country for
institutions and support for a free and
fair election
and that they will say is a high crime
and a misdemeanor and if it isn't
then there can be no rational definition
for this country going forward
as to what is a high crime and
misdemeanor because they will argue if
you're as president of the united states
the most powerful position politically
in our country
and you wage a month-long campaign to
undermine faith and confidence in a free
and fair election
and then when a riot storms the capital
and you do nothing to stop it
what how else could that not be a high
crime and misdemeanor and they will ask
republicans
to dig into their conscience and ask
that question and try to come up with an
answer
different than the one we saw yesterday
do you expect the president's lawyers to
engage directly
with that challenging concept the
president brought up the fact that the
election was in his words fraudulent
stolen people went to the capitol in his
name wearing his name on the hats with
his name on the flags
are they going to engage directly with
that complicated legal matter
only by accident and because of their
performance yesterday you have to allow
for possibilities that they will
accidentally do something they don't
intend to do because yesterday's
performance
was by all accounts even president
trump's a pitiful one
so that's always possible but no they've
already said what they're going to argue
the president has a first amendment
right to talk about things he thinks are
important
and he didn't incite there's nothing
directly insightful about his language
on that day
they will not deal with the long-running
campaign to undermine confidence
in the election itself and they will say
those who committed those acts of
violence should be prosecuted
individually for
actions they undertook of their free
volition and they'll pretty much leave
it at that and also say oh yes by the
way
the constitution the way we read it at
least doesn't allow you to impeach
someone who's no longer in office
the house managers yesterday made a very
compelling case that the constitution
does
what i think is interesting about that
tony is i've spent 30 years in this town
listening to republicans tell me over
and over about the importance of the
textual
verifiable language of the constitution
and everything about the debates around
the constitution and our
attachment to british law house
democrats made that exact
case yesterday and republicans looked at
it listened to it
and then looked the other way what do we
know about the former president trump
and how he feels about what he saw
unfold on tv yesterday
he did not like it he was not pleased in
part because it was such a weak and
rambling defense
of what the president did or didn't do
also
the president likes his attorneys to be
killers to have great presence
those were not killers on the senate
floor they didn't have great presence
and they barely made an argument yeah i
can't imagine the president not being
happy that one of his lawyers
acknowledged that the house
presentation was pretty good major not
only that
but that the country made the decision
and he didn't win the election and oh by
the way he might be prosecuted someday
not exactly what you want your defense's
counsel to uh bring up before the united
states senate
he may have needed a good long walk
after watching that major garrett thank
you very much
sure